let's see if we can take the derivative
with respect to X of the fourth root of
x to the third power plus four x squared
plus seven and at first you might say
alright how do I take the derivative of
fourth root of something it looks like I
have a composite function I'm taking the
fourth root of another expression here
and you'd be right and if you're dealing
with a composite function the chain rule
should be front of mine but first let's
just make this fourth root a little bit
more tractable for us and just realize
that this fourth root is really nothing
but a fractional exponent so this is the
same thing as the derivative with
respect to X of X to the third plus four
x squared plus seven to the one fourth
power to the one fourth power now how do
we take the derivative of this well we
can view this as I said a few seconds
ago we can view this as a composite
function what do we do first with our X
well we do all of this business and we
could call this U of X and then whatever
we get for U of X we raise that to the
fourth power so the way that we would
take the derivative we would take the
derivative of this you could view it as
the outer function with respect to U of
X and then multiply that times the
derivative of U with respect to X so
let's let's do that so what this is
going to be this is going to be equal to
so we're going to take our outside
function which I'm highlighting in green
now so where I take something to the 1/4
I'm gonna take the derivative of that
with respect to the inside with respect
to U of X well I'm just going to use the
power rule here I'm just going to bring
that 1/4 out front so it's going to be
1/4 times whatever I'm taking the
derivative with respect to to the 1/4
minus 1 power look all I did is use the
power rule here I didn't have an X here
now I'm taking the derivative with
respect to U of X with respect with
respect to this polynomial expression
here so I could just throw the U of X in
here if I like actually let me just do
that so this is going to be X to the 3rd
plus 4 x squared plus 7 and then I want
to multiply that and this is the chain
rule I took the derivative
of the outside with respect to the
inside and I'm going to multiply that
times the derivative of the inside so
what's the derivative of U of X u prime
of X let's see we just going to use the
power rule a bunch of times it's going
to be 3x squared plus 2 times 4 is 8 X
to the 2 minus 1 is just 1 power first
power so that's just I can just write
that as 8x and then the derivative with
respect to X of 7 well derivative with
respect to X of a constant it's going to
be 0 so that's u prime of X so then I'm
just going to multiply by u prime of X
which is 3x squared plus 3x squared plus
8x and so well I can clean this up a
little bit so this would be equal to
this would be equal to actually let me
just rewrite that exponent there so this
1/4 minus 1 I can rewrite it 1/4 minus 1
is negative three-fourths negative
three-fourths negative 3/4 power and you
could manipulate this in different ways
if you like but the key is to just
recognize that this is an application of
the chain rule derivative of the outside
with well actually the first thing to
realize is the fourth root is the same
thing as taking something to the 1/4
power basic exponent property and then
realize that ok I have a composite
function here so I can take the
derivative of the outside with respect
to the inside that's what we did here
times the derivative of the inside with
respect to X and so if someone were to
tell you if someone were to say all
right f of X f of X is equal to the
fourth root of x to the third plus 4 x
squared plus 7 and then they said well
what is f prime of I don't know negative
3 well you would evaluate this at
negative 3 so this let me just do that
so it's 1/4 times C you have negative 27
I hope this works out reasonably well
plus 36 plus 36 plus 7 to the negative
three four it's what is this result to
this is going to be equal to this is
this right over here is sixteen right
negative twenty seven plus seven is
negative 20 plus thirty-six so this is
sixteen I think this is going to work
out nicely and then times 3 times
negative so three times nine which is 27
minus 24 so this is going to be right
over here that is going to be three now
what is 16 to the negative three-fourths
slimmies is 1/4 times so 16 to the 1/4
is 2 and then you raise that to the let
me actually I don't want to skip steps
here but this is at this point we are
dealing with algebra or maybe even
pre-algebra so this is going to be x
times 16 to the 1/4 and then we're going
to raise that to the negative 3 times
that 3 out front so we could put that 3
there 16 to the 1/4 is 2 2 to the 3rd is
8 so 2 to the negative third power is
1/8 so that is 1/8 so we have 3/4 times
1/8 which is equal to 3 over 32 3/32 so
that would be the slope of the tangent
line of the graph y is equal to f of X
when X is equal to negative 3